les élections sénatoriales sont issus
des municipales de 2014 et pas d'élu en
marche en 2014 l'autre le corps
électoral était plutôt à droite le corps
électoral que le corps électoral et à
droite nous nous allons perdre des
sièges d'alors aussi que j'espère un
chiffre la droite va en gagner le moins
possible j'espère la droite continuera à
être majoritaire au sénat c'est évident
quelqu'un qui voudrait dire linverse ce
serait une langue de bois absolument à
gruissan il y aura de nouveaux élus la
république en marche sans aucun doute
j'aimerais tant d autres j'ai entendu
des chiffres d'intel et j'ai entendu des
chiffres ont déjà une aura cinquante ou
soixante donné les devants dans la vie
on aura deux fois moins donner un
nouveau pronostic semaine ouvert mais
c'est pas un pronostic c'est une analyse
sorti groggy et à gauche au ps a beau
nous on va en perdre
évidemment on en a perdu 20 ou 25 lors
des dernières élections là ne les
élections municipales nous sont
défavorables on va peut-être en perdre
le même nombre le moins possible je sais
pas comment avec ses goûts et c'est
aujourd'hui que vous pouvez donner oui
mais tout le monde dit la même chose on
sait que les départements qui ne
bougeront pas et des départements où on
risque de baisser
je vais pas vous raconter des histoires
dans l'élection disent on va la gagner
on ne va pas la gagner cette élection
est la droite va la gagner et la droite
sera majoritaire au sénat
raison de plus pour renforcer le groupe
socialiste et pour faire venir au sénat
pour faire élire des sénateurs de gauche
qui pour en faire ce contrepoids à la
droite qui de toute façon sera
majoritaire ce que je pense pour
répondre clairement là encore sans
aucune langue de bois
gérard la rue de l'arche est à mon sens
sera président du sénat le 2 octobre
alors